und jetzt ist mir professor dr klaus
dieter zastrow zugeschaltet guten morgen
herr zastrow ja erst die bilder aus
berlin von der hasenheide wo ganz viele
menschen tausende menschen feiern jetzt
die bilder aus bulgarien
wie gefährlich sind diesen
massenaufläufe ja von jugendlichen
wirklich
na ja vor allen dingen wird viel
getrunken wird sind natürlich immer
übertragungs trächtig also die gefahr
eine krankheit weiter zu verbreiten ist
natürlich bei solchen einrichtungen
sonderveranstaltungen besonders groß
auch bulgarien haben wir natürlich denke
ich wenig einfluss aber die
veranstaltung bei uns
die können wir schon sagen wir mal ein
bisschen kontrollieren
ich bin nicht der meinung dass das wir
das grundsätzlich verbieten sollten es
ist sommer es ist warm die leute waren
auch doch schon eine ganze weile
eingesperrt und wenn wir die maske
tragen und ich muss noch mal sagen wenn
es ärger ihn und auch endlich mal sagt
der träger schützt sich und zwar
ausschließlich mit der maske dann haben
wir auch eine zweite welle ist wurde
jetzt schon angedeutet ja zweite welle
die welle die wir damals hatten da gab
es täglich 45 6000 neuerkrankte und
damals haben wir gehofft dass wir unter
1000 kommen da sind wir jetzt und es
geht mal mehr und mal weniger
also ich denke gefährlich ist dass in
bulgarien und die leute werden ja nun
vielleicht auch getestete rückreise aber
wichtig ist für alle gesunden maske
tragen und dann kann ihnen nichts
passieren